the migrants who are living inside the
Suites hotel in knowsley watched on as
police continued to investigate white
protests here turned violent it had been
a peaceful demonstration until a group
of people armed with fireworks and
hammers arrived hurling missiles at
officers before attacking a policeman
and setting it on fire one officer and
two other people were injured as police
struggled to regain control
Ahmed who arrived in the UK a month ago
saw it all happen from inside the hotel
I see some people fire police car
and some people support us but only how
did you feel afraid sure afraid we hear
uh UK in the safety when come
sometimes afraid a shot
last weekend a far-right organization
delivered leaflets in this area and
posted a video claiming people are
outraged that migrants are living here
unverified footage on social media
appearing to show a migrant talking to a
15 year old girl sparked anger locally
the police are investigating but have
warned of the risks of rumor and
misinformation
I've just been speaking to two local
women who didn't want to go on camera
but say they were at the original
peaceful demonstration they say they
came here because they're concerned
about approaches migrants have made to
children in the area when I asked them
if they had any evidence that that had
actually happened they said they'd seen
comments on social media and accepted it
was all hearsay
Claire Mosley who was part of a counter
protest in support of the migrants was
listening to what the women had to say
this is not the Britain that I know if
people people don't want Asylum seekers
in hotels then they need to tell the
government to process their claims and
let them work if people even these
ladies who I believe are very
misinformed if they think a crime has
been committed then you report it to the
police we do not have mob rule on our
streets
the MP for knowsley believes anger here
had been fueled by misinformation
there are people there who've got an
argument to make which is against asylum
in general
and they're using platforms to promote
the idea that there's a massive problem
with Asylum Seekers interfering with
children or young girls
the police say there's no evidence that
that's happening on a scale at all what
reports they have had they're
investigating and people should wait
till the police have investigated them
but as the debris left by the fire was
cleared the police will remain here
aware that tensions that caused the
violence have not gone away Becky
Johnson Sky News nosley